okay hi everyone we are
going to be doing a
design review as part of our incremental
language development
efforts of various upcoming features for
future versions of of language okay
let's start off with once and once again
so the issue here is
um
once
in a particular session can do do an
operation
and then cache the results right
right
and
remind me let's see so
actually what exactly is the semantics
of once
the second argument is the persistence
location so by default it's kernel
session but you could have it be local
or cloud or whatever
okay so this is
right so any any code that is given
inside of once
it could be in a a right so i mean it it
can be in some
function
it's an initialization mechanism that
could be an ongoing code but this is the
initialization and it will not be rerun
right
by the way do we have a link here to
with cleanup we probably should link to
with cleanup here
does that make sense to you guys
i think so we can add it
okay
um
and this should link to once somewhere
okay so now
i see
right so this is
run the code
with once explicitly rerun
right
right
so it's it's like
um
what is the way of unquieting a quiet
is that possible
right i don't know maybe it isn't
possible
so we have dollar messages to look at
messages that may have improved
i mean it's
again would be like quiet
it's similar to clay
where you know it's turning it off
so what are you saying i'm saying the
analog
is is our client is already the analog
right quiet turns off message within
the code once again turns off once
within the code
i understand yeah
but i'm saying what about the the other
one
which is unquieting quiet code so to
speak
and i mean my point is this is like
unquoting the quote of the quote of the
unquote or something i don't know
seems like it needs a general mechanism
okay so we've got this idea
of
you know
things that
inhibit something quiet and once are
both inhibitors once there's an
inhibitor of repeated evaluation quiet
of message generation
so the question then is
how do you
deactivate
that kind of thing
what are other examples of that
no well in other words where a wrapper
causes evaluation-like changes to its
sub to its sub-expressions
so well of course block lets you do it
for anything
right and block random and things like
that so in a sense it's almost like
block quiet block once
right
and again it's something that you can
run again and again
or it would work only once
it'll work yeah as many times as you
want
well so but i mean the question is what
if it was called block once
yeah that's that's a
less clever but maybe better name
so then the semantics would be
so it's like block random
um
well is it in fact the right thing here
so so block random
takes the external random state
yeah and then does its own thing here
but this is unwantsing this is a gaining
um
okay what would if we had a block quiet
what would it do
how would it be different from quiet
because the whole point is it unquiets
the quiet that's oh i see it okay okay i
see not a block where things are quiet
where you're blocking quiet
um
the other possibility would be a second
argument to quiet where you could rap
but i don't think quiet of quiet does
anything terribly interesting
i mean the other possibility would be
right i mean like check has the third
one check you can turn
check for certain messages and not for
certain messages but quiet only has four
certain messages
right steve is commenting that um uh
yeah once again it's definitely a better
name than once than again rather i agree
with that but i'm not sure that that's
the right i don't think again is the
right thing i mean
the other major design point that you
want to think about is
is all it does block
once
or are the new
results cached for the next time once is
used outside of again
right does it mess with the cache or
does it not mess with the cash right
well block once would be the notion of
we're going to ignore the once i mean
what that would mean just like block
random says
ignore the random seed that was ambient
do your own random seeding and throw
away the random thing you did inside
so i'm saying it's scoping of random
seating right and what this will be
doing is scoping of once
right so
but it can be can be quite confusing
it's hard to hear you oh sorry
you're just quiet you seem like you're
destined for a microphone or something
go ahead say it again
okay can you hear me now is it better
you're still quiet but it's okay now is
it now better yes
okay good so they are tweaked okay so i
mean the
the
uh implementation given at the top here
would just i mean it would just undo the
one disable the ones when it's one but
afterwards the previous result of the
months would come back which is probably
not what anybody would expect right i
wasn't taking this as an actual final
implementation yes now my my my point
about this is i don't think
this is necessary because it's quite
easy to delete all the ones caches in
your session especially if the purpose
of this is for debugging or for
development
how do you delete them well look at the
look at the web page and at the
neat example i don't care about neat
examples i want to know does it tell me
right here how to delete them
okay you you have to delete the caches
but they are persistent objects with a
certain name which you will find
in that example
so
points are already off here roman for
the fact that it doesn't say it in the
in the main documentation
but
the fact that i have to go to a neat
example to find it out is a bit
disappointing but there are two there
are two issues one is you can
put all the onces in a particular
session in a separate cache and then
delete that cache or you can just delete
the default cache
in
uh
uh roman this is pretty obscure yeah yes
i just found i just saw that that's not
what i meant it must be somewhere else
let's see
well why is that red and this there's a
lot of obscurity here why is that red
that's a buggin
and syntax coloring right
yes
yes it is
okay okay
right
um but to me
okay look block once
to me
it's a little bit weird name
but
what it means semantically is the same
as block random means which is
i had a state
i'm going to ignore that state for
running this code
i may create new state while running
this code i'm going to throw that
straight away at the end of the at the
end of the scoping block
yep
so i mean
i think it's semantically right and i
think block quiet will be the same type
of thing
now i i wonder
let me think about this i'm not um
uh i mean one could imagine other things
like with confirm one could imagine some
kind of block now maybe not now that's a
different thing
that's a different thing i mean the
point about these is
no actually this is even more obscure
because block quiet doesn't make sense
because the quiet would be
oh gosh what does that mean because the
quiet will be in code inside the that
scope
right and what you want to do is grab go
inside that so in this case block once
it's like there's already an external
state for once just like there is an
external state for random
making sense so i mean if i say
echo you know random
random reel here
and then i say
um
okay great i don't know how to test this
exactly
um
you have to have a random seed
yeah yeah right
right
okay but i mean do you get what i'm
saying that this is analogous to the
random case isn't it
yeah quiet is weird yeah i see what you
i see what you mean you can't redo the
quiet in a different
state
because yeah it doesn't make sense that
way
unless you imagine
that there is an ambient
list of things that will be quieted and
you could imagine that block quiet can
change that ambient list so the default
here for example
i think that's kind of weird
yeah i think this
analogy to
quite a message is confusing things yes
okay all right but so
okay so the the the possibility here i
mean look we can implement a function
repository function for block once and
see see how you know
i think that's what i think that's the
right place for this
actually i just found the example it's
in properties and relations i mean it
could probably be put put for for the
for deleting the caches that could be
made more prominent
the the last example there
okay roman this is deeply obscure i mean
this is deeply deeply obscure because i
wouldn't know what other you know like
like
if we had a block once
there is the possibility
that you could say what you are actually
blocking
so to speak
right because this i would be very
nervous about doing a delete object of
you know
yeah
i mean this is like super scary who
knows what else you've have yeah it
might be for entirely different
operation that you don't want to
clear well in this particular case these
persistent objects are in kernel scope
so they go away when you create the
kernel anyways i know that but
arm is done
and in fact i don't agree roman i don't
agree i don't agree because let's say
you've got a giant you know two hour
initialization you did in the kernel
right
and then
you've got another tiny initialization
that you did
this function that you're running makes
use of the tiny initialization and you
want to redo the tiny initialization but
you sure don't want to blow away the
two-hour initialization
you see what i'm saying
yes but i mean if you have trouble with
once if
once misbehaves that you need to
tinker with it you probably shouldn't
use it in this early stage of
development anyway
well okay but i think i i'm now getting
more and more sold on the idea of having
something
which
re-runs the the once now okay so now the
next question is
how would you rerun the global once
that is you have a thing so your notion
of again
was just
right which once again is a better name
i like that better yeah once again it's
better but i mean the
what would be the argument of once again
i mean that's a different thing that's a
different what this is doing is
given all of the onces inside its scope
run them again exactly refresh them
refresh them act as if their expiration
date has come
or
yeah
does once have a refresh mechanism
no it does it has the unset thing
it has an expiration date thing what
does it where does it have that oh there
right okay
yes i mean this this just does it once
right i mean when the once is created
then you can set the expiration date
now
of course the other question is
if because once is kind of uh like a
cache and for example if you look in a
browser when a browser needs to
decide whether to fetch resources again
there's there's the notion of of a
timestamp of a cache expiration
and it would be possible to have an
option of once that
would indicate any arbitrary
calculation that would give a timestamp
so
when once is encountered again it would
check first check that whether that the
re-evaluation
expression has changed
if it has then it would we do it a month
but that's still that doesn't solve this
problem though it sounds nice it's a
different product yes yes but it's an
interesting idea you could check a file
date for example before you read
so if the expression inside once refers
to an external file you could give the
file date of that file as a
re-evaluation check
i like that idea just like the browser
does essentially i like that i do very
much i mean
um
i can i can put the example in in the
chat if you like
right
if they're still cloud connected it's
the same account you can keep using the
same value if they've changed use a new
one this yeah that sort of thing
all right so that will be like
reevaluation test arrow whatever yes yes
oh that's exactly what you called it the
evaluation check okay
so
why is it called a check why is it not a
reevaluation test
wait a minute this if the reevaluation
test is
true
then reevaluate
is that correct
or if it's unchanged it's like oh i see
i see i see that's why you're calling it
check because
the question is okay so that
there are two possible things you might
want
the one you're suggesting is probably
better that is if this
changed
then reevaluate yes
and the other idea would be that kind of
a test and if the test returns true or
false then we evaluate yeah right
exactly i'm not sure we need both but
well let's think about other scenarios i
mean one is a file
um
did that change
um
what are some other things well yeah i
think i think did it change is really
the issue because that's what
you know the username those kinds of
things
i like this it's a good idea um
i mean yeah could also have uses for the
more pers more persistent the ones
caches i mean you can you can
use local local objects as as caches
which would survive kernel restart
then maybe the evaluation check could
test whether you are still in the same
machine same username or whatever
well the same session id i mean because
you could actually call
you know dollar session id
is the check for whether you're in the
same session
although by default this is not
necessary because the
cache is tied to the session and it goes
away when the session goes away
right yes no i understand that all right
could be the notebook id of the
evaluation notebook that sort of thing
this is a good idea let's evaluate
re-evaluation check is that the right
name for it
um
what do we call this in uh
that's okay it's a generalization of a
modification date right
typically modification dates are used
for validating caches
but here there is no obvious
experience no obvious
modification date you have to provide
the expression to use as the
modification indicator
right question is is check the right
name
re-evaluation i mean because what this
is is this is the thing which if it
changes
then reevaluate
um
i mean really this is a re-evaluation
this is a this is a token which if
changed causes reevaluation so what's
the right name for that
um
anybody on our live stream got a
brilliant idea about this the
um let's see there's a good word for
this what is it
i don't know why i'm thinking about
nonces but they're the opposite of this
uh
it's a thing
it's not the signature it's not the
validation we could i mean you can think
about it from the other way as if it's
the same you keep it and you could call
like cash validator
um
[Music]
and then perhaps recheck or something
like that
say it again re i mean it will be lovely
if it could be an argument but i think
it can't be because of that persistence
location thing
um
i think it i mean we have expiration
date and persistence time which are
similar concepts as options too so
i think it makes sense
um
gosh what is checks it's it's well it's
not a check sum but
no because some check sum is done at the
time of yeah i mean it's something
expression yeah go ahead it's it's a
short quick evaluation that gives an
indication of whether the whole thing
needs to be redone
right
typically it would be
a
property of an external or persistent
things such as a file
right
um
timestamp is too
too narrow right doesn't
isn't it isn't it it's not a time it's
not um
right so the thing is the thing gets
evaluated once at the time when the once
is first you you know it's first set up
right check
gosh what is the right name for this
this is an expression
that has um
i don't think check is a bad term
you could call it cash check
something like like your luggage claim
check is a similar thing right
do the ids match
do these values match okay i'll take it
so i think if you just see cash check as
a
what's that go ahead yeah i mean it's
it's i mean it sounds funny but it's
it's probably correct correct
description of
i sort of prefer this reevaluation thing
because i think it's easier to
understand
it tells you what it does it checks
whether it needs to evaluate
but you see it doesn't do the check
that's the point it is a
value yes a signature or a
reevaluation proxy something closer to a
proxy
check a value check expression check
object
because it it's something you are going
to check it's the value that you are
going to check whether it changes i know
but the problem is the word check will
be read as a verb in that case
the concept of check
right right i wasn't even understanding
when it said reevaluation check i wasn't
understanding that that was a
noun form of check
oh i see
i see
i was also looking for a verb
well right but so what is what are some
names
um
receipts
that's really weird
um look proxy
it isn't the right word but it's
something closer to the right thing
it is a proxy for
it is something which you can
and why am i thinking it was like totem
and so on which is hardly the right kind
of thing but you you get what i'm saying
it's the thing which stands for
surrogate
yes
um
it's the reevaluation
oh gosh what is the right term
it reminds me of well
you see time to live
that's what you know persistence time is
is time to live basically jeremy
suggested tag in the chat that's not
terrible
oh tag is just a generic
i mean tag is just so
evaluation tag
problem is that i you know
tag is just too
kind of it could be anything
although i admit that it's i think it's
better than check
it's also a luggage related thing
no i'm just it's our luggage
signature which i thought was at least
along the rhine lines
i don't know if re-evaluated it's not a
signature you see that's the problem
it's not it's the um
there is a word and maybe maybe from
some crypto place there's a way to
this is and it's like a hash but it
isn't a hash
it's a
it's not a proxy it's not a um
make it a hash of expert and just
completely
ruin the point of the watch
exactly
i
do whimsical two whimsical yes
there's something in the space we'll
we'll get it we'll get it i'm not sure
charles on a livestream suggests
expiration token
it is not terrible
reevaluation key steve suggests
it's not quite a key
token
eric suggests uh criterion i don't think
that's quite right because the thing is
it is a thing it's not a criterion it's
a it's this thing and as soon as this
thing changes it's a signal to
reevaluate
revaluation indicator that's wrong as
well
um
evaluation trigger
that's not terrible
i mean at least that's
the problem with reevaluation
trigger is it suggests that it's
continually evaluated well it sort of is
continually evaluated actually
um
not quite right because the thing that
triggers it is when the value changes
maybe something along that line that's
right
richard is commenting on consistency
criterion yeah i mean i agree that the
question is is the cash consistent or is
it invalidated
validation
how about
how about
validation expression
yes that's possible
would make it clear that
it's the expression value itself that is
exactly
i think that's our least terrible one so
far
which is just inconsistently predicate
but it's not a predator it's not a
predicate you're testing whether the
value remains the same
and it's not a clock either because it's
some
suggesting tracker as in tract symbols
yes that's also possible
um
and that would actually also be a a good
use case because at the moment
once doesn't look for changes to
symbols inside expo so you could
actually just give a list of symbols to
check
right so they changed right right right
that's a good point
right so that's that will be the tract i
mean you could imagine
we have a notion of tracked symbols one
could even imagine
actually now that i think about it
um you know attract symbols option to
once independent of this
right that will be for indirect
dependence
which you could also get from the
validation experience yes i mean it is a
very special case
and it it doesn't deserve more than a
prominent example for
using a list of symbols inside the
validation expression
so far i'm liking validation expression
best um
so you're suggesting cash certain cash
key i don't cash that i don't get at all
cash the
um
and cash expiration isn't right because
it's it's the this thing
will be reevaluated as a as a
as a test for whether
this once is still valid or whether it
has to be reevaluated
um
[Music]
okay look initially i'm thinking
validation expression is our best bet
right now yeah i can proceed with that
fine now let's just go back to the
original question which was the the
blocking of what of of once
the
external blocking of once that is
you have a piece of code it's got onces
in it you want to rerun the onces
and do you want it so the two questions
you want to rerun it and restuff the
once
back into the you know basically just
kick the onces and refresh them
okay or do you want to block the
operation of once for this code
evaluation
both of those things
yeah i mean it would be very strange if
the previous value of france would
survive
so i think the option is to to re-stuff
them or to delete them
well with black ones
yeah i don't agree with you i think it
could be a thing okay so let's think
about this the thing the scenario i was
imagining was you have a block of code
you want to say what would happen if i
ran this code without
the cash
that was the scenario i was describing
um
and you're describing the scenario of i
just want to i mean look this is the
thing i i had some nasty bug recently
that was a pure once needed to be kicked
type situation
um
yeah i mean my my general comment is
still that maybe
in this case what you shouldn't have
used once in this particular case
if if it doesn't really
if the expression is so
fragile or
no it was good it would be wrong it was
a it was a stupid obscure complicated
bug well that's right i think it was uh
was that my verse data thing yeah yeah
yeah yeah it was yeah
i just had a i had a bug in some code
and i sent it to steven and he ran it
and it cashed with the values resulting
from the bug and then i fixed the bug
and i sent it to him again and he read
it again and he stealed all the cash in
a session so my fix didn't appear
right
right so that was a case where i think
it was an import or something like that
that was being done
and
the the once yeah right the the code
that was an indirect change
where
that's right that's right the issue is
the following the issue is attract
symbols issue that is the code said you
know bob's import or something right
and the once said oh great i already
knew i already did that
the problem was there was an indirect
dependence because
bob's import had been changed
right exactly
which is getting
you know messed up by
by attract symbols assume not
and i mean in that case what i would
have wanted to do was just say
just say clear the caches
so maybe what we want is a
maybe what we wanted something different
again from any of these which is just a
thing that says
clear the cache in the session
or clear the cache wherever the
persistence location is
clear either
you know clear once well that's a
terrible name it's a terrible terrible
name i mean we have we have cache
we have a general function for clearing
system caches right
maybe we just need to add another case
to
what is it what is that
what is it called clear stem cache
is that what it's called
there is
what on earth is that that does some
very obscure caches right
yes it's exactly the same kind of thing
like numeric caches for
your 10 million digits of pi or
something like that
so it's really similar it is very very
similar motivation right yeah it is
except that's a sim that's a system
cache
perhaps this is more a case for onset
and set of their ex ones well onset
just takes a particular ones as an
expression but the
there is a way which
there should probably be a more easy way
to just clear all the ones caches that
there are what was the thing with the
onset what does it do
that that clears an individual once
so if you have usually say onset of once
of export and that particular ones is
cleared
and that's that's documented in the
notes of once
what if um first you could do
persistence objects
of
all comma once
and then delete object on it
yes i mean it is a bit as steven pointed
out a couple of minutes ago it is a bit
obscure where they are and they're
correct
an easier way to
to obtain
the active caches
okay so let's roll this back a second so
i mean the first point is
i didn't know about this unset of once i
think that's a acute and weird
thing
and i would not be unhappy to have an
actual function i'm sure we did that
because we didn't think we wanted to
make once too heavyweight with seven
functions around it
um
so in real use cases it's almost never
practical
in my experience
why if the once is deep in some code
you have to go in and modify the code
and do onset load the code run it all
then go back remove the onset
load the code run it again right so the
the use case that we think is a real use
case is a state dependent you know is a
is a total side effect thing that just
says either
we can imagine a couple of things we
could say rerun the onces
or or blow away the answers
well we're running will always happen
after you blow them away right i know
that it'll happen it'll happen at the
time of evaluation you might but there's
no other way because as bob said they
could be deep somewhere inside depending
on local variables and stuff like that
although you certainly knew what they
were because when you blew them away you
already had the expressions right there
yeah but it doesn't it doesn't remember
it doesn't remember
the state of the evaluator right it just
remembers the implications so your point
is right yeah so so in a sense we could
have a bug because we could have two
once of x you know once x
could occur in different places in the
code in one place x is three in the
other place x is five
yes but i mean the the second one would
never
would never evaluate because the ones is
already there
and it just looks it it looks at the
expression hash
and if it's the same symbol in the same
context
obviously if it's module variable it's
different because it has that dollar
dollar
number attached so it's a different
symbol
right you know and also useless because
next time it runs the module will
generate a different value so
once we symbol what with module values
variables is probably points
yeah
okay
um let me see so yeah i mean
there is a way which we could make
easier to just blow away all the onces
in your current session
or there
could be a way to
block them but i would see that no
i'm beginning to
cool on that idea so to speak i think
that's not the relevant idea i think the
relevant idea is
either you know blow them away
okay so what on earth would we call that
um
what kind of clear system caches do we
currently have if you expand that
detailed section then we can probably
okay so that's
very specific this isn't a system cache
the system cache is something quite
detailed
yes you're right i mean this is an
escape valve function this is not a
an everyday use function
uh
we have clear cookies which is similar
right so clear is the right kind of name
but clear once is clearly a
misunderstandable name so it would have
to be clear clear once cash
i mean if there were
a
function that returns all the ones
caches
which is more
which is not as obscure as the current
example
and
you say delete object of that but i
think that's a
i mean is it worth smile to have a
specific function to delete all the ones
caches
and if you and the first time you use
them you will need to search for it
anyway so you will look at the web page
of once and there you will also find it
so so we're not concerned with this big
initialization little initialization
thing anymore because this won't help
that right
well it would if you fed in the the the
tag of the once here
as you put in the expression tag for the
once that you want to clear you can do
it
how do you know the expression tag what
how do you know the expression tag
oh i see you're saying when it came in
it could have a thing that had evaluated
yeah because in the once it could have a
value and if you have that expo
the ones argument then you can just use
onset then you don't need any of that so
the question is really what do you do if
you don't want to dig inside
but really how many times do you want to
clear one
cache and not the other one
rather than just we're starting your
colonel
yeah i kind of agree but i think the
point about this is
it's part of not having to restart
colonel but i can see if if you imagine
a world where people commonly use local
object caches though then it becomes a
bigger problem because it's very likely
that they want to
avoid some and not clear all of them
i switch you're saying if this was not a
session character if it was not a
session attached if it's a local object
or
you know or any of the other second
arguments to once
then
right i mean do we want this clear once
caches to touch
local objects or just kernel session
right
yes and i mean if you go if you provide
a second argument to once then you're
already dealing with you're already
deciding where to put them
and then you can just put those advances
that you want to deal with at the same
time in a industry now you're just
saying local all you're saying is yeah
you know you you can you can still have
the expression right yes but you can you
can you can give you'll never think of
it as the time before you ran into the
bug that caused you to want to you know
invalidate your once caches you would
never have pre-thought oh i might run
into a bug
nobody ever expects a bug
maybe that's just optimistic programmers
never expect a bug
yes but i mean this will happen only
once right
first time you run into problem then you
decide okay i quit the kernel but now i
use specific no way so no way
there are too many optimists
um
all right let's let's okay we've still
this is still problematic we still have
not figured out what we want here
because
i agree that blowing away a local object
cache or worse cloud object cache just
because you you know were upset that
something didn't run correctly and then
you blow away these giant caches that
you built
um
you know
a year ago that store some giant piece
of data that you pre-computed that would
be a bad idea
well but for that particular case using
relying on implicit caches is also a bad
idea then you you should use a name
local object for for your result i kind
of read it
explicitly right i mean if we have this
clear once cache the zero argument form
should by default at least just do
kernel session caches
then it's not horrible yeah it should
the argument the argument should be just
like the persistent object i mean you
you can give a persistent location the
default would be the same default as for
once obviously
it would just make it easier
but
you need to you still need to remember
that function so if you're going to
look at the
web page of once you will find whatever
it says there how to delete them
whether it's a new function or
a console i was i was reading some of
the comments on our live stream here
richard is commenting on
um
let's see
you could use you could flush a once
cash without updating and you could
force reevaluation
yes i agree with those statements
um
um
okay and richard is commenting if you
say x equals once of expert and then
unset of x
no and the problem is unset of x is
going to
it's only going to see the expo the once
is gone by the time you say x equals
once of expert the once is just you know
a caching rapper
um
steve is suggesting clear of once doing
something custom with once i don't think
that's a good idea because i think clear
has to be its own has to be purely
remove
rules associated with a particular
symbol well i agree these are rules
associated with symbol but not rules in
the sense that
um
we expected
uh
craig is suggesting about printing a
warning to the console using a cache
with a creation date
i don't think that's a great idea i
think this is a the problem with any
printing is it's okay when it's your own
code and you're looking at it and you're
debugging it but when it was you know
three generations away from you of some
thing that you were using that was
somebody else's thing that was somebody
else's thing and so on it's like it
prints a message it's like what on earth
is this
um
yeah so the the there's the possibility
of clear
okay so that's an interesting idea clear
of wants of something
do any other clear work on any other
objects
no
but
it's called onset it is
it is i mean clear might be a better
name but it might be a better thing to
use but i believe clear only works on
symbols
right
doesn't allow the possibility
okay look i think we have to let this
percolate a bit um i mean i think we've
got the other question is whether we
want to be able to have something which
gives you all your once caches
which i think you brought up and
persistence
objects is too obscure for that yes i
mean at the moment you can you can
obviously list all your persistent
objects that are once caches but you
don't see where they came from because
they just use the extra hash right as a
name
and so whether we need a browser for
once caches but i mean have you ever
looked at the cache of your browser
isn't that just something that
okay
yes i have
because i don't want to blow away the
whole cache
because i'm i'm you know some something
has gone wrong with the cache
but i don't want to just say blow away
all my browser caches because it's like
i've you know some random website that i
logged into you know three months ago
and i don't you know and i i it's not
worth i don't want to blow that all away
yes but then i mean then you probably
just do ctrl shift r for the page that
you want to reevaluate
without caches
sure i've certainly done that but but
yes okay but sometimes i wanted to
particularly with debugging our own fine
cloud infrastructure where i want to
just remove all caches associated with
some domain
but look i admit that these are obscure
cases
um all right so look let's break out the
different cases of this and we're going
to have to come back to this again i
think we've got validation expression
um
we uh
i think we've killed off the idea of a
block quiet a block once
i think what we have right now before us
is
essentially
a
a once refreshing function and how that
should work
okay and how globally it should refresh
whether it should go and whether the
argument of the of the um
refresher could be by default session
and you have to explicitly say
local if you want to
clear the once caches at the level of
local objects
so we've ruled out something
that's scoping
for the code within it i think so i
think that's not that important
i think i mean somebody could try and
write a wfr for that
see whether that is useful
but i don't think the scoping thing is
is um i'm not i'm not buying the scoping
thing right now i mean i'm mostly buying
the
something went wrong it's just like with
a web page you know
whatever it is you know shift reload or
whatever right
something went wrong i want to run this
without caching
right but that's that's exactly the
scoping case isn't it it's the scoping
case
in my mind it is
if you're just refreshing
we got other items let's try and get
through some other items here before we
run out of time um
can we bring this back please with a
with a recrispened version of what we're
talking about here
yes yeah yes
okay bye thanks
type signature numbers and data set
so we have michael to explain this
you jeremy probably should here it's the
direct use of it
okay
great so
uh
in
we recognize wayne is a fairly specific
context in which we want to be
formatting our outputs in particular
ways and and by default things get the
traditional form
um
on all the output cells but there are
some of our resource functions that
produce
associations of that sort of recreate
the pod experience of that you get on
the web
and
we use data set to do that but
internally to all of these research
functions you have to
use the second example here where you
have item displaced function going to
identity
in this sort of awkward way and if
somebody were to
ask for a data set of an association
output it would oh yeah let's cut to the
chase the main issue is for some
absolutely freaking crazy reason data
set is turning symbolic pi into a
numerical value is that correct
yep okay that seems bonkers
to me
i don't know the reason it has always
done that so i think it's crazy i think
it was one weird case and somebody
decided it was a good idea
there are more examples in the in the
last subsection just in case
it doesn't always do it it's kind of
see the seven halves
works but bigger numbers do not
seems crazy it seems like
a
you know
it seems like one of these
things which was a good idea for one
particular example
yep
i it just seems wrong to to
do this numericalization in general
yeah it feels a bit odd in invoking
language yeah i think it's the wrong
thing i think i think there should be an
easy way to do it if you want it
to do that i mean the thing that drives
me crazy and i think we still need to
fight is trailing periods
in you know
exact numbers
sorry
things where i get the numerical value
but it is an integer
it drives me crazy for display that
there's a period after you know three
dot
for something like a presentational data
set i just don't want that dot
see what i'm saying
but this is again a little this the flip
side of what we want to look here at
like if the data set isn't about
real-world data but about mathematical
results of curve analysis of riemann sum
or something like this you might well
want to differentiate between 3 and 3.
well no doubt
no doubt i'm just saying
i don't even know with number four more
decimal form or any of these things how
to get
like like what happens if we do decimal
form
of three
dot and why does it do that but in my
form only operates on
one rules
what is decimal forms objective it is to
produce
without scientific notation okay exactly
i hate this i hate this trailing dot
so we have removed it in a few places in
graphics and in for example in percent
form if you do percent form
it will remove that
thank goodness
um
but why does decimal form not remove it
well i think this is michael's argument
that
in some cases you really need to know
whether something is exact or not
and and
yes but i think those are those are
fairly corner cases in my opinion i
think the most much more common cases
i've got a nice table of results i've
i've got them by numerical approximation
of various kinds
and it is an exact number as far as i'm
concerned
but for example imagine a list of
these numbers and it's packed
right so if you don't see the dot
it may be
very misleading well i mean i end up
having to have all kinds of weird rounds
in various places
to deal with this problem anyway this
problem i don't think is the problem
that you came here with the problem you
came here with is an insanity and data
set where it's numericalizing the the
numbers and it just seems wrong to me
what's the analysis of we just removed
that feature at and replaced it with
something where there is
what what is the thing that allows you
to specify the format
that function data item display
function
which is a function for data set
and other things it's probably other
things and it takes several arguments
by the way why is it i just want to
report this again
that that this is the typing into that
input field is sluggish
this probably has to do with the
autocomplete but it's really wrong
it seems to be just for data set here
okay so i think the question that is
before us is what's the default for item
display function is that correct
i think it would be just numbers so
i mean item display functions four
numbers
yeah i get it i mean what's the default
item display function four numbers
and right now we have some wackiness
going on and i we just need an analysis
of whether that whether there's any
good thing achieved by this wackiness or
whether it's just causing trouble
my only guess is that there may be some
numeric expressions with roots and
things like that that are very large so
this will just produce more consistent
tables
yeah well maybe so maybe it needs some
kind of automatic value
that
okay
that's the question the question is if
it's going to be big
and you know that the symbolic root of a
cubic or something
then
what does it do
right then then does it
yes i agree that that will make a total
mess of the dataset formatting unless we
have another mechanism for displaying a
giant
i mean it reminds me of sort of
spreadsheets where they where they
they do horrifying things horrifying
things
um
okay so that's the issue the issue is if
one of these
things that really is just a number gets
big because the root of a cubic or
something
then how do we deal with this
all right
am i confused or is that that basically
yeah i think that's the reason why
this by the way drives me crazy why i
can't see
okay so if i say cubics arrow true
okay there we go so those those would be
typical weird crazy numbers
but if you have such a number then you
might probably want to see it
i would rq
no
it depends what it depends on the
situation i can see plenty of cases
where you have a data set you've got one
of those things in it and it just looks
like absolute garbage it just ruins your
data set
but
if it didn't auto collapse if everything
was symbolic
you would probably i i i disagree i
think the opposite you want
if it's in the data set you probably
wanted to preserve it
otherwise i wouldn't have put it in
and if you want
you can change the item display function
to a function that will
either with a particular specification
if you know where it is or something
that can handle it
sort of as you're expecting
but
it
seems like that should maybe be left to
the user to decide
okay
what we don't have is an analysis of
what will break
if we look at examples of data set that
we have for example in the data
repository let's say what will break
if we change the default item display
function to not mess with the contents
right we don't know the answer to that
so we need to know the answer to that if
the conclusion is nothing will break
then
but i i wouldn't say the word is break
it's just going to look different no
it's going to look terrible it's going
to look look i can manufacture a data
set that will be completely unformatable
in any reasonable way by having putting
putting stuff like this in this is not a
thing that is going to
i mean unless we have a mechanism in
data set to deal with a giant cell
but that would be the alternative is
some kind of iconization of a giant cell
and that might be a reasonable solution
here
we do have an option item size i think
right but that's not necessarily quite
the right thing i mean we could have a
thing where it it literally iconizes for
example it it auto iconizes in that cell
that wouldn't be totally crazy
above a certain size it it produces an
icon there
and and what we could do is by default
we could paint into the icon as the
as the kind of name of the icon some
kind of appropriate summary of what was
in it
that seems reasonable to me and that way
it's all there if you even want it in
the data set you just press the
uniconize button
does that make sense
so what i mean by that is i i'm talking
about explicit on explicit iconization
so we literally would be saying i can
eyes this
but we would attempt to put in the icon
as a in the
in the name of the icon
of the iconized form something that is
helpful to see i think this is the right
solution guys
do you understand what i'm saying so so
this is a sort of auto iconization
threshold in a data set
i think that's a good
solution there
um
okay
so
the plan would be
change item display function
to be
identity basically hey look if you're
gonna say something please say it
yeah if you wanted to see something that
basically where this would be greatly
improving what i've just put in the chat
okay
something just beeped what the heck
beeped here
michael that's a very extreme case yeah
of course
and why did i get talking about
basically mass
data sets with when some formulas are
long
my gosh i've never seen that error a box
structure where the depth exceeding the
maximum allowed depth was encountered
i didn't even know we had that message
it's probably been there for
30-something years
trust michael to find it
did you know that message was there
michael
no i didn't see it
ever before
no i have seen it before i mean not
right now but i have sound turned off so
i didn't hear the people
okay fair enough
there um
okay in any case um
all right i think we have a potential
solution can you work through whether
that will actually work
okay
yep
um we are running out of time here and
um
uh there's a question from ic
asking why i we may have the wrong set
of people here why
this is one of these undoubtedly the
wrong set of people why is why are
populations of countries before 1960 in
scientific notation probably because
they don't have accuracy bounds but i
don't know michael might know
this is 80 correct we looked into
getting accuracy bounds but we're not
able to get them
so it's just an estimate
right
and we don't we don't even know kind of
is
how many digits position
i see
that's the kind of information that i
wonder whether we have any way to
document
why do i think this is not a simple
discussion exactly i was going to
mention that yeah
this looks very complicated
that
hey what do we do when we go
into stella
what do you mean
well i don't know this only works for
the solar system what happens when
there's a you know
a um
i'm i'm joking here yeah i'm i'm
well just for my curiosity
so spacecrafts have their own time
systems
i'm sorry what the spacecrafts have
their own
oh my gosh
is that barycentric dynamical time
yeah that's one of the ones we have
so wait a minute you're saying that a
random spacecraft going to jupiter
has its own time system
yeah it's on
totally different way of controlling
time by
ticks or something
yes so now does that have significant
relativistic corrections
um
well probably is
probably it can be measured yes
it was with
good clocks
yep
so
okay i see so so i mean
for the
people who take a you know a spacecraft
trip to mars
it is the expectation that they're
they won't be using utc
so why not by the way why wouldn't they
just use utc
because they will
the natural thing will be to synchronize
with their own rotation
days
so mars will have its own right
once they get to mars but when they're
on their spacecraft why wouldn't they
use utc
oh because they will follow the clock
that there is in the computer
which is which has time dilation
um well it has its own mechanisms and
probably they can reset it from
earth and things like that
so the important thing is that the clock
is determined the time is determined by
the clock of the spacecraft
i understand as opposed to the the clock
of the earth which is which matters
whether there's an earthquake and it
changes the leap seconds
that's your point exactly yeah
yes and presumably mars has sleep
settings as well i don't know it doesn't
have much of a liquid core does it
um
i think it may have a tiny one but not
much
um
i think there are mars quakes though
um
anyway but but so who knows and and i
don't know how long it will be before
anybody knows the leap seconds of mars
um
the
mouse orbit is also rather unstable so
you probably have more lots
what
more
corrections
mean the orbit of the planet
yeah but yes i mean it because it is it
is right there being influenced by
jupiter and saturn so the long-term
survival of mars is not guaranteed
it's not a stable orbit huh
it's been around for a while though yeah
i mean it's not not as it does it would
crash it in the sound tomorrow but uh
it's it's not always it might not make
it for the whole lifetime of the sun
yeah it's not it's it's not obviously
difficult to predict the long-term
uh orbit of mars
okay i think we should probably this is
this is clearly a significantly longer
topic and and the issue
boy oh boy oh boy oh this is going to be
interesting all right
oh my gosh have you gotten all this
stuff to work jose
sorry
have you gotten all this stuff to work
now
uh yeah
yeah for julian dates and also the we're
finalizing it working in data objects
it's not through the whole date system
but
as a container data object can take a
time system and to handle conversions
between time systems
and do arithmetic accounting for time
systems etc how does it deal with okay
this is my last curiosity question we're
not going to be able to cover this
properly today but how does it deal with
time dilation
in other words isn't it the case that
there are identities that will be true
about times that will not be true if one
of them is in a boosted frame
okay so these time systems are already
prepared for some locations and so for
example one is on the surface of the
earth the other is at the center of the
earth one is at the
uh the earth moving around the sun the
other is at the center of the sun things
like that so those are the values the
center of the sun not accounting for the
fact that the sun has
uh you know there's no gravitational
redshift association exactly exactly
it's at the center of the earth or the
sun if they weren't there right
exactly
but but so none of these systems have to
deal with the possibility that the
elapsed time that if you try and make
essentially sort of a commutative
diagram of you know you elapse time in
this system then you you add yeah here's
the issue the issue is you add 10
seconds or you know 10 years or
something you add 10 years
on in this place then you subtract 10
years in another place you might not get
back to where you started from
right yes
we don't consider that so what is here
is for example the fact that because the
earth is moving and it's actually moving
in an
elliptical orbit
the difference between the time on earth
and the time of the sun
are
has oscillations due to speed changes
so that's considered here but there is
always a one to one correspondence
between time in one place and time in
the other place
typically linear linear with corrections
so
i see but the but the
the time dilation is not accounted for
so the thing that i described the
arithmetic time arithmetic will fail
okay that this is basically
it's kind of interesting case right so
the case i'm talking about is you go you
go 10 years
forwards
then you
in a time system centered
at a place with you know gamma or or
gravitational
you know
field such and such
then you go to another place with a
different gamma different or different
gravitational field then you subtract
the ten years you don't get zero you
don't go to where you start from
i see i see what you mean so when you
have a date object in some time system
and you are 10 years you are adding 10
years of that time system
or only of that one and so
there is no commutativity in that sense
because you had 10 years at the sun and
10 years at the end at the earth they
are different 10 years
so you end up in different instances and
you subtract them and you have a
difference something non-zero
because of time dilation or because of
the just the way the time systems are
set up because yeah it's time time
dilation you don't know whether it's due
to gravity or speed but it's time
dilation
huh
well that's interesting
okay i think we have to leave this for
another time actually i am supposed to
do another live stream about um
uh
history of science and technology q a
okay
well those are interested i'm going to
do that but um thanks to folks here
we've clearly got an interesting
cliffhanger of discussion here for next
time about time systems